these days major movie studios mark
their spots on the release schedule
years ahead of time and it seems like
audiences have to wait forever once a
film is announced but before you know it
we'll all be buying our tickets for
Summer 2018 s hottest big-screen
blockbusters from superhero sequels to
explosive crime thrillers to
mind-bending horror flicks it looks like
there's a whole lineup of films that are
well worth the wait among the dozens of
promising projects slated for release
here are some of the movies that are
going to hit big hereditary according to
critics hereditary isn't your
run-of-the-mill fright flick it's a
movie that's going to leave you shaken
to your very core starring Tony Collette
hereditary tells the story of a family
dealing with grief after the passing of
a grandmother unfortunately grandma
might not be gone and she might not be
so friendly the a/v Club
described the film as pure emotional
terrorism and it's got an ending that
daily dead compared to movies like
Carrie in the which in other words
prepare yourself for some cinematic
trauma ocean's 8 using the same basic
premise of Ocean's eleven a group of
quirky cons pull off an incredibly
elaborate heist ocean's 8 has done a
gender swap a movie like this relies on
the likability of its cast similar to
the George Clooney version ocean's 8 has
assembled one of the very best teams in
recent memory with an actor lineup this
awesome it seems likely that ocean's 8
will totally be able to hold its own
against Steven Soderbergh's classic
debate to steal stock yes Incredibles to
14 years after the release of The
Incredibles our crime-fighting family is
ready to save the world yet again and
Incredibles 2 is going to pick up right
where the old one left off as for the
plot the exact details are hard to find
but we know Craig T Nelson's mr.
incredible will be staying at home
watching after his super-powered baby
while Holly hunters Elastigirl goes on
an adventure and stretches her
superpowers to new limits Bob Odenkirk
and Catherine Keener have also joined
the cast and while we don't know who
they're playing yet there's a good
chance they might be some sort of
dastardly duo
watch the kids no problem Jurassic world
fallen kingdom when Jurassic world
roared into theaters in 2015 it quickly
became the fourth highest grossing film
of all time raking in nearly 1.7 billion
dollars now with Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom not only will we get to see
raptors run amok but we'll also watch an
abandoned theme park get blown to
smithereens
directed by Jay a Verona this
blockbuster promises to be an
over-the-top spectacle complete with the
return of Jeff Goldblum's Ian Malcolm
it's pretty safe to say falling Kingdom
won't go extinct at the box office life
[Music]
finds away Sicario day of the Soldado
you wouldn't necessarily think a movie
like Sicario needs a sequel but rest
assured Sicario day of the Soldado is in
good hands Sicario scribe taylor
sheridan the genius behind hell or high
water and windriver wrote the screenplay
resulting in what's bound to be an
incredible thriller according to the
independent director Stefano sollima
promises a more cinematic film than the
first featuring quote an incredible
amount of huge action sequences we're
also going to get a film that's far
darker than the first with the returning
star Josh Brolin describing the story as
severe and Sheridan telling indieWIRE
that Soldado makes the first one look
like a comedy
the first purge the purge franchise has
been picking off victims and making
political points since 2013 but now with
the first purge we'll get an answer as
to how this night of bloodshed all
started
directed by newcomer Gerrard McMurray
and written by franchise mastermind
James demonaco the newest film will take
place before the Ethan Hawke original
demonaco told Entertainment Weekly that
the cast will be 90 percent black adding
to the film's socio-political message
naturally the film is set to hit
theaters on July 4 when fireworks will
light the sky and blood will flow in the
streets ant-man and the wasp audiences
are in for a marvelous time when ant-man
and the wasp arrives on July 6 with
Peyton Reed returning to direct both
Paul Rudd and Evangeline Lilly will be
suiting up as the titular heroes
apparently the pair will attempt to
rescue Michelle Pfeiffer's Janet Van
Dyne from her decade
long adventure lost in the quantum realm
Lily told Vanity Fair if we do succeed
an ant-man and the wasp then that does
open a whole entire new multiverse to
enter into and play around in in other
words things are going to get super
weird after infinity war the equalizer -
ready to see a super assassin and
hardware expert dispose of some
gangsters with gardening tools your
dreams may very well come true on August
3rd when Denzel Washington returns for
the equalizer - reteaming with director
Antoine Fuqua Washington is making
history here starring in his very first
sequel there aren't a lot of plot
details out there but come on we're
going to see Denzel destroy a bunch of
bad guys in incredibly creative ways
what more do you need to know Mission
Impossible fall out Tom Cruise's Ethan
Hunt is at it again
you know family thing director
Christopher McQuarrie returns to helm a
sixth installment to the covert op
action-adventure series McQuarrie has
promised that we will quote get to know
who II think and that our action hero
will actually go on an emotional journey
maybe that's why Michelle Monaghan is
returning as Ethan's old flame in
addition to a killer cast we're super
psyched to see the crazy stunts cruisin
McQuarrie have cooked up crews trained
for a year to prepare for some truly
insane action sequences and we can't
wait until July 27th to see how the
superstar puts his life on the line this
time the Meg cue the creepy music
because the Meg is an ancient shark
that's tormenting deep-sea fishermen and
this adaptation of the bestseller Meg a
novel of deep terror the film features
Jason Statham as a rescue diver who must
help a stranded submarine and this crew
escape the teeth of the prehistoric
beast shark movies automatically earn
creeping dread just by their nature but
this flick looks to take us into the
depths of our fears it's literally
dropping the distressed crew into the
deepest parts of the Pacific Ocean so
we're in for an action-packed treat
captive State John Goodman is revisiting
the sci-fi genre with captive state an
alien invasion thriller from Rupert
Wyatt the director who gave us Rise of
the Planet of the Apes
according to the official plot
description the film is set in Chicago
nearly a decade after an occupation by
an extraterrestrial force
captive state will focus on the lives on
both sides of the conflict the
collaborators and dissidents and we
can't wait for this science-fiction
flick to invade movie theaters on August
17 white boy Rick at only 14 years old a
Caucasian teenager from Detroit named
rick wershe jr. was recruited as a
snitch by the FBI he went on to help the
feds arrest some dangerous drug lords
before becoming a big-time dealer
himself a story this wild was just
begging for someone to make it into a
movie
and fortunately white boy Rick is set to
hit theaters on August 17 as real-life
Ricky story recently took a strange turn
it'll be interesting to see how these
events will affect the film white boy
Rick promises to be one of the craziest
true crime stories of the year Mandy it
seems like Nicholas Cage's entire career
was leading to Mandy all the freaky
faces the on-screen breakdowns all the
awesome Nicolas Cage moments were
building up to this the result is a big
bloody of explosion of LSD weirdness and
battle-ax action mixed with rage pain
and a lot of vodka
Mandy finds caged playing a man who
embarks on a revenge mission in a film
that according to the verge combines the
most absurd aesthetic excesses of 70's
and 80's horror films with the most
absurd thespian excesses of Nicolas Cage
which obviously makes Mandy sound like
one of the greatest movies ever made the
nun the conjuring series is quickly
making its case that horror movie
franchises can also become extended
universes following in the successes of
the franchise's first spin-off Annabelle
producers have given the demon nun from
the conjuring to her own film simply
titled the nun the plot which may be a
prequel to the conjuring 2 involves a
priest who is called in to investigate a
nuns passing in Rome if there's anything
we've learned about demonic presences in
Hollywood history
it's that Italy tends to provide quite a
creepy backdrop this will definitely be
one to watch
Robin Hood we've had Errol Flynn Kevin
Costner Cary Elwes Russell Crowe and an
animated Fox now it looks like Taran
Edgerton will dawn Robin Hood's
trademark green tights Robin Hood is
going to be like a medieval version of
Batman Begins showing us how Robin of
Loxley became Great Britain's most
famous bandit according to Deadline the
movie will take place after Robin
returns home from the Crusades only to
find that Sherwood Forest is now rife
with corruption and evil Jamie Foxx
who's playing Little John says the movie
quote looks like you're watching zero
dark thirty taking Robin Hood in a dark
direction is certainly an interesting
choice and with the winning combo of
Edgerton and Fox the upcoming action
flick could be one of 2018 s most
exciting movies the house with a clock
in its walls
Eli Roth isn't really known for his
kid-friendly films but he's looking to
change things up with the house with a
clock in its walls based on the classic
children's book this Gothic fright flick
tells the story of a ten-year-old boy
who's sent to live in a quiet Michigan
town with his uncle who turns out to be
a warlock there's also a witch next door
plus an apocalyptic clock hidden in the
walls of course and things get
especially tricky when our hero
resurrects an evil being this spooky
movie is set to scare kids on September
21st thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]